nous devons trouver des solutions
innovantes pour que le kiné moins de
femmes qui est de problèmes quand elle
sait c'est de développer leur business
[Musique]
mélanie mme capitale c'est en fait une
banque la première banque
d'investissement digital à un pacte qui
est dédié totalement à l'afrique et à sa
diaspora ce qu'on cherche à proposer à
travers notre technologie c'est des
produits d'investissement qui sont
adaptés aux investisseurs privés locaux
et aux investisseurs privés de la
diaspora pour qu'ils puissent financer
les entrepreneurs à impact dans leur
pays d'origine et ainsi contribuer au
développement de leur pays
[Musique]
être femme entrepreneur comme chaque
métier dans lesquelles nous nous sommes
des femmes c'est pas forcément évident
mais nous avons la chance de pouvoir
travailler avec des partenaires qui est
cherche à promouvoir l'entrepreneuriat
féminin c'est le cas également de notre
partenaire absa bank au kenya qui a
sorti avec nous un programme 100% dédiée
au renforcement des capacités des femmes
entrepreneurs on cherchait à financer
ensemble 1000 entreprises qui fit qui
aide les femmes à travers des emplois ou
à travers l'entrepreneuriat
[Musique]
l'afrique est un continent où les femmes
sont extrêmement active est en général
sont celles aussi qui entreprennent le
plus le problème c'est l'accès aux fonds
l'accès aux financements qui a encore
trop faible quand on regarde même les
statistiques des femmes qui arrivent à
lever des fonds en tant qu'entrepreneur
roussillo de start-ups assure réduit au
fur et à mesure des montants
d'investissement on arrive peut-être à
monter des à
lever des petits fonds mais pas des
grands des grandes levée de fonds et
c'est quelque chose que nous devons
changer et pour cela il faut aussi
changer l'écosystème en afrique
[Musique]